when angenette's friends bring up
um our personal matters i felt kind of
not necessarily attacked but i was
totally unprepared for that
why don't you trust me
[Music]
i trust you internet i trust you
why why did you say that i i hooked up
with another guy
when i was here and then i got pregnant
in the united states
what now you're sweating a lot because
i'm asking you that question right now
i i don't remember saying anything like
that no i stopped lying ryan because
it's all that in front of my face
i i really i don't know what to say
right now internet
i think that you guys need to talk more
honestly with each other
well i've tried i've tried to talk about
it but but you don't want to
you don't ever want to because because
you said that your your mom
your mom doesn't want everybody to know
about it you told me that
in front of my face well i i thought you
didn't want to discuss this in front of
everybody that's why
no i don't i don't i don't want i don't
want to talk about it when
it is just the two of us because i'm
sure you're going to be mad again
so i think she's saying she feels
comfortable talking about with her
friends here
and you should feel comfortable too
because you got your family here
if i if i said that i might have been
drunk no you're not drunk before royal
because we just we just finished eating
that before
we just finished eating our dinner and
then you were just sitting on the couch
and then you said that on the sofa and
you said
well i don't remember saying that
because you don't know how it feels to
lose a town
why are you not talking while you look
like an idiot in there
sitting and not talking
i was shot when and janet said all those
things about royal you know saying
anything
it's like she tried to destroy him
they're so used to not talking in the
house like he's been trying to talk to
her about this
for months and she'll tell him that she
does not want to talk about it and i
know these things i know all the ins and
outs
are are you scared that i'm gonna yell
at you i'm am i scared that you're gonna
yell at me
no we yell at each other people yell at
each other sometimes you just have to be
able to tell the person either calm down
or yell back i mean
what you're going to have conflict in
every relationship
if you're scared of them don't be with
[Music]
them
you